der letzte Adventskalender
unglaublich wow war das dieses Jahr eine
Reise ne das waren Auf und Ab der
Gefühle das waren sehr viele Kalender
sehr viele ein Kalender hat es dieses
Jahr auf Platz 1 geschafft wenn es darum
geht wie oft ich gefragt wurde ob ich
den denn auspacke und das ist der Fay
pflanzenadventskalender ich bin bei euch
ich verstehe auch nicht wie es ein
Adventskalender mit Pflanzen geben kann
deswegen finden wir das heute heraus
denn er ist angekommen yay ich hatte
gehofft den ein bisschen früher zu
bekommen aber ich hatte dann gehört dass
wohl der noch nicht ganz fertig war und
die da noch irgendwie ein paar Türchen
füllen mussten wir sind ja immer in
Kontakt mit einen Herstellern um da
irgendwie schneller Adventskalender zu
bekommen aber ja der hat leider nicht
früher geschafft das heißt vielleicht
könnt ihr i euch noch im Rabatt so im
Sale dann kaufen wenn euch gefällt aber
sonst ja ich habe heute die
weihnachtlichen Türchen da im
Hintergrund aufgestellt es hat gestern
abend geschneit im November es ist
verrückt so wir holen ihn jetzt erstmal
hier
raus der letzte Kalender ich bin richtig
emotional sorry wenn ich heute
vielleicht ein bisschen komisch bin oh
ich sehe schon ein bisschen
[Musik]
Erde tada wie pflege ich die Pflanzen
wenn Kalender hey ich habe eine frage
wie überleben die Pflanzen im Kalender
ohne Licht wir haben extra robuste
Pflanzen ausgewählt denen die Dunkelheit
nichts ausmacht damit Sie schon mal in
ihr neues zause Spen können haben wir
zusätzlich kleine Lichtschlitze
eingebaut keine Sorge ihnen geht es
blendend
ah Lichtschlitze das Gefühl hier ist es
jetzt ein bisschen sandig
geworden
au
Alarm Alarm fängt ja schon mal toll an
dieser Kalender kostet jetzt gerade 150
€ hat aber glaub ich auch auch schon mal
200 gekostet und das ist ein
Adventskalender mit Pflanzen ist toll
eine Bitte habe ich noch an euch wenn
euch mein Content gefällt dann abonniert
mich doch gerne denn ich möchte
unbedingt jetzt einmal die eine Million
Abonnenten erreichen und diesen goldenen
play button bekommen ich ziehe jetzt
nämlich im Dezember in mein Büro und da
wäre natürlich schön wenn im Eingang so
ein 1 Million Euro 1 Million Euro 1
Million Abos Play Button ist könnt ihr
euch überlegen fühlt euch nicht unter
Druck gesetzt ne ist nur so ich sag noch
einmal los 150 dur 24
6,25 darf jedes Türchen Kosten muss
nicht kann ein letztes Mal für dieses
Jahr Türchen
Nummer nach über 30 adventskalenderv
Videos dieses Jahr tut es mir wirklich
sehr leid dieses Video ist natürlich
nicht gesponser und jetzt alle ein
letztes mal dieses Video ist nicht
gesponser
ein Pflanze drin ach süß das dieser
Kalender das ist eine erdige Geschichte
ne ja muss man so ein bisschen
vorsichtig sein Türchen Nummer 1 ich
glaube es do nicht es ist wirklich halt
ein pflanzenkalender juhu endlich geht
es los ich freue mich riesig zu Hause
angekommen zu sein lass uns gemeinsam
den ersten dezember feiern in den
Türchen gibt's immer so ein QRCode und
da kommt man noch zum digitalen
Adventskalender glaube da gibt's dann
auch eine Pflegeanleitung und Hinweise
zu der Pflanze Nummer Z what ich meine
ich weiß dass da Pflanzen drin sind aber
es ist so komisch eine Pflanze da
rauszupacken wie ist es dir dort in dem
kartonergang
unglaublich in Türchen Nummer 2 ist eine
Pflanze drin nein doch das einzige
Problem ist natürlich ich bin kein
pflanzenexperte
Ende der Durchsage aber sie sieht sehr
hübsch aus toll wenn man sich auch
kleine Pflanzen holt dann kann man
erstmal üben dann hat man noch nicht so
eine große Verantwortung
Nummer d er Advent jetzt haben deine
beiden Pflänzchen ein zu Hause ah ja ich
habe mich schon gewundert kommen ja so
im
Dings jetzt haben sie ein zu Hause komm
kannst zu Hause einziehen die Töpfe
fühlen sich so ein bisschen ja die
fühlen sich so ein bisschen an als ob
sie mit einem 3D Drucker gedruckt worden
falls euch das irgendwas sagt erster
Advent ich finde nur sie hätten in jedes
Türchen so ein Loch reinmachen sollen
weil so sieht man ganz genau wann eine
Pflanze drin sein wird an den
Luftlöchern die sie für die Pflanzen
gelassen haben Türchen Nummer vier
Pflanze der Kalender muss auf jeden Fall
irgendwo stehen wo es dreckig werden
kann die werden die werden
wahrscheinlich beim Transport von den
Boten und so ordentlich
durchgeschüttelt aber dafür sehen sie
noch ganz fit aus ne optisch sind wir
hier natürlich sehr ähnlich bei der
ersten Pflanze angekommen das sind halt
die die im Dunklen überleben können
tüchen
Nummer ich würde dich am liebsten
umarmen so pflegeleicht wie ich bin
werden wir wir uns sicher prächtig
verstehen was ist das für eine Pflanze
was ist das was ist das denn für eine
Pflanze das ist ein Blatt was aus der
Erde rauskommt ist das eine Pflanze
dieses Blatt immer größer kommt ein
zweites raus was bist du hat Wurzeln ja
meine Lieblingspflanze okay ein letztes
Mal es ist Nikolaus wir gehen an unseren
Adventskalender und schauen was drin ist
ich glaub es
nicht
Pflanze aber die Erde schon bei jedem
sehr trocken ich weiß nicht ob das
Absicht ist damit das irgendwie besser
reisen kann oder so aber die Erde ist
schon furz trocken ich glaub die geht
auch noch mal ein bisschen auseinander
die durch diese kartonform so nach oben
gepresst wurde das sind wirklich viele
Pflanzen ich habe aber eine Theorie bin
mal gespannt meine Theorie stimmt Nummer
7 ich sag es ist kein Loch drin also
werden Töpfe drin
sein so
vorausschauar meine Kleine
Blattpflanze
und du kriegst auch ein zu Hause Nummer
hier haben wir ich sag mal ein kleinen
Unfall oder was ist das das ist der
perfekte letzte Kalender sage ich euch
ja das ist der perfekte letzte Kalender
weil danach werde ich hier auf jeden
Fall saugen müssen und ordentlich
aufräumen müssen ist natürlich eine ganz
andere als die anderen zackigen aber süß
kleine Pflanze aber sehr viel Erde
verloren so eine kleine macht so viel
Dreck überall Türchen Nummer ne ist das
beste Türchen ein letztes
Mal denn das ist meine
Lieblingszahl das ist in Türchen drin
eine andere Art Topf vorher hatten wir
so 3D Drucker gedruckte und das fühlt
sich nach Keramik an ne gleich Zind zu
Hause ja ist okay also ist vom Design ja
es ist ein schönes Töpfchen also würde
ich mir auch genauso im Baumarkt oder so
aussuchen Nummer ze
hat wieder ein Loch wir wissen was das
bedeutet eine neue Pflanze
guck mal die sieht anders aus ich glaub
ich lass die Watte dran wenn ich die
Watte abmache kommt so viel Erde runter
das das ich habe jetzt schon genug zu
saugen es wäre natürlich super toll wenn
ich jetzt zu jeder Pflanze irgendwas
tolles sagen könnte und ah und hier und
die kommt in da und da vor und ganz
interessant zu wissen aber ich kenne
mich nichts auf dieser Welt aus Nummer
schauen wir doch mal was in Nummer 12
drin ist oder Nummer
12 ich bin jetzt
vorsichtiger oh soll das Topfuntersetzer
sein oder so Untersetzer Schut her
Topfuntersetzer ich gehe mal stark davon
aus ein topfuntersitzer ist okay 13 ja
ich glaube wir sind durch mit den
Pflanzen noch eine Pflanze kommt nicht
sieben Pflanzen waren jetzt hier drin
und ich sehe sonst keine Tür mehr mit
einem Loch also bin ich gespannt womit
jetzt der pflanzenkalender noch gefüllt
sein soll Nummer 13 Einladung in den
Member Club eine Mitgliedschaft scanne
für formularus genieße 3 Vorzüge der
Mitgliedschaft okay hat hier eine
mitgliedschaftskarte und dann genießt
man Vorteile ich denke dann mal so
Rabatte und sowas 14 in Türchen
14 sumsum die kleine Hummel freut sich
in deinen Dschungel einzuziehen biege
einfach die beiden drte bei ihren
Flügeln und Steckel sie in deine Pflanze
es ist so eine Metallplatte einfach und
dann hast Du hier diese zwei Dinge
okay und dann hat deine Blattpflanze hat
hier dann so eine Biene ich habe mir
noch nie in meinem Leben gedacht dass
meine Pflanze Deko oder ein Anhänger
oder so braucht weiß ich nicht diger
Nummer 15 also ich sehe schon dieser
Kalender wird mich noch überraschen oh
was passiert hier ein Töpfchen Glück für
dich Glücksklee zum Einpflanzen bevor du
das Glücksklee eintopst nimm dir einen
Moment um an fünf Wünsche zu denken
jedes wachsen Blatt soll ein dieser
Wünsche tragen aussart ist März bis
August und Blütezeit ist Juni bis
September genau sowas habe ich mir
vorgestellt für so ein
pflanzenkalender was essen Pflanzen
gerne Blätterteig oh es ist
schlecht oh ja hier bin ich doch mal
hier bin ich dabei Dünger Pellets genau
für diesen Kram LEBIG das sind nämlich
düngerpellets und man soll ja auch seine
Zimmerpflanzen düngen und das mache ich
nie weil ja ich weiß auch nicht für mich
hat man eine Pflanze und dann gießt man
sie für Zimmer und Balkonpflanzen wirkt
bis zu 6 Monate einfache Anwendung das
mache ich auf jeden Fall kriegen gleich
alle meine Pflanzen kriegen so ein
Dünger es ist ein Zeichen für euch
Dünger zu kaufen und eure Pflanzen zu
düngen ist auch so ein geiles Wort ne
Dünger es gibt so Wörter die wir einfach
akzeptieren ja das ist Dünger Dünger
Dünger
Dünger geh zum her oh die 17 ist gleich
daneben da machen wir dich auch mal auf
das ist nicht gut man muss die irgendwie
von oben oder so aufmachen das ist
so
schwer Rubbellos ja ein Rubbellos
ne was habe ich jetzt mit diesem
Rubbellos so findest Du heraus ob du
gewonnen hast scanne den QR-Code und
gelange zur gewinnseite ne lass mal
Nummer
Sticker find Sticker so cool ich liebe
Sticker Sticker sind toll mein Gott
Sticker cool cool cool soll ich sagen
das sind Sticker
ne
19 das macht mir Angst was ist das was
zur Hölle ist das was soll das sein es
riecht nach so holztanne und SAS Rose
von Jericho nein ich bin nicht tot lege
mich ins Wasser und ich blühe
auf das machen wir so Kinder jetzt sind
wir hier bei einem kleinen Experiment
also wenn das jetzt hier nicht richtig
toller Effekt ist ne ich ich leg es
jetzt einfach mal ins
Wasser Rose von Jericho ma wir jetzt ein
[Musik]
Zeitraffer 20 Minuten spter okay das
dauert bisschen länger als wir dachten
ich lass es hier einfach mal stehen und
wir machen weiter wir sind in den 20ern
angekommen was kommt hier Putztuch für
Pflanzen was viele nämlich immer
vergessen ist Ihre Pflanzen zu
entstauben damit sie auch besser atmen
können die Grenze zwischen Dichtung und
Wahrheit ist für uns oft unsichtbar das
ist absoluter Quatsch ich weiß nicht ob
die so atmen aber auf jeden Fall ist ist
gut für die Pflanzen wenn man sie staubt
ja das ist halt so das ist ein ganz
einfacher standardlappen
21 uh da ist man richtig ausgestattet
sage ich euch eine
pflanzenschere richtige pflanzenschere
perfekt für die
Vermehrung ah damit man dann einen Ast
abschneiden kann und dann jetzt dar du
Friseur vertrocknete Blätter abzwacken
Stecklinge schneiden den Bonsai Stutzen
dafür ist unsere pflanzenschere ideal
ich weiß nicht ob es normal ist dass sie
so laut ist
22 jetzt kriegen wir hier den guten
scheiß oh war nur abwärter Zuhörer
wurzelboster verstärkt Wachstum
erleichtert stoffaunahme der
wurzelbooster Doping für die Pflanzen
brauche ich meisten sehen nämlich gerade
bei mir nicht so glücklich aus
23 ihr wisst was ich von Beuteln denke
der riecht fair produziert kann man
nicht errichen aber er riecht nicht nach
Plastik er riecht nicht nach Chemie
beudel für alle die es nicht wissen ich
packe so viele Adventskalender aus und
in so vielen Adventskalendern ist
einfach ein be in und ich finde man hat
genug Beutel es gibt einfach genug
Beutel man kauft sich mittlerweile jetzt
ja auch Beutel im Supermarkt weil es
keine Plastiktüten mehr gibt bzwch dann
keine Papiertüten egal
Beutel l jetzt saug dich doch mal
vololl du darf nicht
sch das letzte Türchen für dieses Jahr
es ist Weihnachten wir gehen an unseren
Adventskalender und hoffen was tolles zu
bekommen in Tür Nummer 24 ist
drin nimm mich mit auf deine Reise Buton
wenn hier jetzt Flugtickets nach barali
drin sind dann bin ich glücklich meine
Reise das letzte Türchen ist offen ist
der Spaß jetzt vorbei papal PAP jetzt
geht's erst richtig los du hast mit
diesem adventsk nämlich das Tor zur
Pflanzenwelt
geöffnet Beutel und ein Button wei ich
nicht muss das
okay
ich
bin und damit habe ich alle Kalender
dieses Jahr geöffnet ich habe natürlich
viele nicht geschafft zu öffnen was halt
einfach daran lag dass es zu viele waren
und ich mich dann auch irgendwie
verschätzt habe und dann kam hier nicht
die ich eigentlich auspacken wollte dann
kam sie dann doch blaa ich sehe hier auf
jeden Fall noch einige Adventskalender
die werde ich aber nicht jetzt einfach
in Müll schmeißen oder sonst was machen
sondern sie an meine Familie auch
verteilen denn es gibt dort ganz viele
die sich sehr darüber freuen ein
Adventskalender dieses Jahr von mir zu
bekommen wenn ihr Lust habt die nächsten
Wochen noch hier zu bleiben macht es
gerne denn es kommt jetzt ein Monat lang
vlogm also das wird quasi mein Video
Adventskalender für euch sein wo ich
jeden Tag das was wir machen Filme und
für euch hochlade und ich hoffe euch
gefällt ich hoffe ich schaffe es dieses
Jahr durchzuziehen es ist für die Leute
die schon länger dabei sind ja wie so
ein running gag dass ich es jedes Jahr
wieder Versuche und eigentlich nicht
schaffe deswegen drück mir die Daumen
und bleib dran ja ab morgen geht schon
los vom 1 dezember bis zum 24 und jetzt
gibt's die Bewertung ich finde dieser
Kalender ist natürlich super cool weil
es ist ein pflanzenadventskalender also
sowas gab es ja wirklich noch nie es ist
mega schlau dass sie so gelöst haben
dass die Pflanzen in den ersten Türchen
kommen und dann später halt keine mehr
dass die Pflanzen so zwei Wochen maximal
in dieser Schachtel so drin sind und
auch wirklich überleben können bis zum
24 kann also kann ich mir auch
vorstellen dass es dann einfach ja alles
eingeht und da finde ich das auch gar
nicht so schlimm dass man dann halt
Pflanzen macht und dann Accessoires ich
muss sagen es sind aber einige
Accessoires da drin gewesen also ein
Button obwohl den den Lappen lass ich
noch durchgehen Button stickerel los
Mitgliedskarte Beutel und ich weiß immer
noch nicht ob das Untersetzer sind oder
tassenuntersetzer hätte ich mal
wahrscheinlich lesen können das sind
also für mich echt schlechte Türchen was
ich dagegen z. super fand war halt
Dünger und irgendwie wurzelbooster und
so gibt's nicht noch mehr Accessoires
oder irgendwie Zusatz was man für so ein
Pflanzenliebhaber machen kann da finde
ich relos Button Sticker das finde ich
halt das sind halt die Füller also das
fühlt sich an wie so füllertüchen so sch
die noch nichts ja mach da mal so ein
gutin Code oder so noch mal da ein paar
Sticker rein Töpfchen finde ich auch
ganz süß
und das Ding ich glaube das Ding kann
hier noch ein absolutes Highlight werden
die Jericho Rose wenn sie dann mal
aufgeht ich Filme sie euch dann wenn sie
aufgegangen ist ja
ne eine Rose würde ich das jetzt nicht
bezeichnen so
also für 150 € ja ja ja doch ja
ja es ist halt sehr viel Erde ne hier
verteilt sich sehr viel Erde 150 € sind
aber völlig okay ich kann mir vorstellen
dass das super viel Arbeit war das alles
zu planen wie der Transport funktioniert
wie die Lagerung funktioniert ich glaube
man hätte sich einfach nur diese
stickertürchen und so irgendwie weil das
muss ja ein Highlight bleiben aber ich
bin sehr froh über all die Pflanzen die
jetzt bei mir eingezogen sind und es ist
immer noch eine richtig coole Idee ne
ein pflanzenadventskalender es gibt
viele Leute die ich kenne die Pflanzen
sehr gerne mögen ach Leute das war's das
war's für dieses Jahr könnt euch nicht
vorstellen wie froh ich bin diesen Raum
hier endlich aufzuräumen es ist ein
Chaos ihr seht ja zum Glück nur diese
Seite das ist alles eine Illusion
Schicht im Schacht jetzt ist Feierabend
Leute es hat mich sehr gefreut dass ihr
mich begleitet habt diese schöne Zeit
lang aber jetzt ist es vorbei bis dann
bis morgen ab morgen geht vlogmas los
Leute W